all right so a little bit of background
my name is paige bailey
um i am dynamic web page everywhere on
the internet
um twitter github everywhere so if you
have any
um questions about the scripts i use and
the scripts that i'm kind of describing
and
later on in the presentation they're all
available on github
in the pi data folder so take a look i'm
founder of pi ladies age techs
i actually have dorothy here in the back
who
who is a member of pi ladies and was
able to come down
i do gis and python development at
chevron my background's geophysics from
rice
and i'm currently a graduate student
there as well
so to get started i guess the initial
reason that i wanted to do a crime
analysis was sparked
by an event in my life i was looking for
a new apartment
in houston and i'm not sure if any of
you have ever
been to houston before but the areas
kind of each each segment has its own
personality
right so if you if you take a look in
there
you can see some some punk thrift shops
uh corporate moles living in the in the
downtown area
saved by new hip condos and i had
very little idea of what i wanted um
what i wanted other than it's near work
which is downtown near my school which
is
rice so that little beige-ish area
towards the south and also near the
metro because unlike most people in
texas i do not have a car
so i rely on public transportation for
everything it's my lifeblood
all right so i finally decided to settle
on this location
it was near arts churches groceries
transportation
um some sort of skin care thing
so whatever whatever happens there um
and then if you take a look over here
there are coffee and tacos so what else
could a girl want right like
it's it's everything i need everything
that a page needs to survive
so as i was moving in um my security
guard
kind of told me as a side note if you
park your car
outside make sure only to park it on
fannin street or truxillo
street and you know i just moved my last
box in and
i thought that was kind of a curious
statement right like
so how can one side of this apartment
building this apartment complex
be more secure than another right
um so i decided to check it out to see
if the statement was true like
and how would i be able to go about
obtaining that data
so the city of houston has
a department police beat crime
statistics website that has monthly
analyses of
every single police beat district within
our unit
and not not aggregated in any manner so
you have 92 police beats
you have 69 months in total for each
police beat and you can
go in and sort of download each csv file
and
individually they also sponsor
a rhodes shapefiles as part of their
enterprise gis system
via the houston open data portal so i
downloaded
like i said manually all of the csvs for
my police beat
and then also the city roads gis file
i was only going to do it for a short
segment so it made sense to do that
rather than writing an extended script
and doing the analysis there's 7445
crime entries for my particular
apartment area
right which averages out to three to
four per day so obviously pretty
kind of dangerous and then each
each crime has a lot of attribute data
associated with it
so a date a time from 0 to 23
an offense type the beat number the
premise code which is kind of like the
building
um description so apartment complex
um grocery store things like that the
block range
the street name and the number of
offenses for each crime
and that's just kind of an overview of
what the premise code entails
so you can check to see if it happened
at an apartment complex
or a grocery store or bar or something
like that
so i noticed as i was doing this initial
analysis there were a lot of
problems with the data i wasn't sure if
the date
referred to when the complaint was filed
or if when it occurred same for the hour
there are a couple of months missing
from the data set that i had to ask the
police for
sort of by name some previous month's
date was intermixed
unknowns and then also there was a
change in the tabular format
some columns moved around but they never
really changed their names
so that was the initial problem
and those are the the kinds of crimes
committed
for my police beat i and then
i also thought about some additional
questions right so when are when are
these crimes most likely did that happen
are they when i'm at home or are they at
night like
or should i be walking around my
neighborhood
um and most seem to occur between the
hours of four and six
and the least between the hours of three
and six am
and i'm not sure there's such a spike in
the afternoon it might be because so
many people are heading home from work
and the number of blocks
for the police beat when i checked where
the crimes were most likely to occur it
turned out
that three of the most dangerous blocks
in houston
are located right by my apartment
complex and that's actually
the three red bars that you see there
were actually the way that i would walk
to work in the morning from 5 to 7 a.m
so 20.6 of crimes and the 10h 40 police
beat
are committed in those three blocks
really close to my apartment complex so
that was kind of scary
right and checking to see if the guard
was actually right
in terms of which sides of my building
were more secure
he was the the sides closest
to those three blocks were where more
auto thefts occurred
and the sides further away were at least
a little bit less dangerous
so a lot of it happens a lot of the
crime happened to occur along the metro
rail as well so like i said those are
the most
dangerous blocks the ones marked in red
and
greyhound station has a high crime rate
as well so
which would be the most safe route for
me to walk to work
like i i was really kind of curious
safety is a big component of everything
we do in the oil industry
so there's a lot of extra effort
involved in making sure that whatever
you do you do it as carefully as
possible
so when i go to work two options i have
wheeler i have ensemble
both are act quite distant from my
apartment and
when mapped it's easiest to see that
probably the best route was to hcc but i
wanted to quantify it
right so i the current
recommended route if i want to go that
way it
as recommended by google is taking me
down this path this 4 000
fan into 3800 fanon um 1100 alabama to a
thousand and then
down main street and the total crimes
along this route
whenever i did the analysis with the
data set that i had pulled was 2.5
2.15 and then
doing a weighted route analysis with the
arcgis network analyst tool which
operates on top of python
reduced the amount of crimes to 1.4
so the modified route that i created
with arc
is moving me from my apartment complex
to hcc
and the times that i'm walking
to there there are four out of 7
445 instances so greatly reducing
the amount of risk that i would be
exposed to
the risk was actually reduced from the
72
walking from walking from my apartment
to wheeler
and going to work and
that's a pretty significant reduction
about 20 times
right so this this initial analysis like
i
said i was doing it for myself but i was
also doing it as part of a class project
and when i presented it i got a lot of
i got a lot of questions like it would
be so great if you could do this for all
of houston
i worry so much about biking home you
know or or could you do this for the
westheimer area right i never know when
to park my
where to park my car when i go to bars
or could you do this along the bayou
i really want to make sure that wherever
i walk my dog or take my bike
i is really safe so
absolutely of course like i would love
to do this for everyone but there's no
way in heck that i was going to do it
all by hand
pulling all the csvs for the 92 police
beats with 69 months of data per police
beat so that
equated out to something like 6 348 csv
files just on different ui
urls and hpd's website so my first
thought was
okay is this even automatable
like could i use automation to do this
so the urls for each police beat are in
a consistent format they
they look something like this houston
texas.gov
police cs stats for a given year
short truncated month name truncated
year and then
truncated month truncated year and
police beat number
so every single one of them looks like
that the tables and associated data
also in a fairly consistent format so if
you do a right click and inspect element
they're all within the span tag like
sometimes the columns change
configuration but that's about it so the
pain points column order had to be
changed
depending on the date and the beat some
months data was unavailable because the
web page didn't exist like the url threw
up a 404
it was utf-8 versus unicode or strings
versus integers for the different fields
dates with this similar formats unknown
values versus empty strings versus nas
versus all of the different things
that if you have any experience with
sociological data or things like
things like scientific data you you get
a lot of different
numbers for unknown items and then the
city blocks names weren't in the same
format as the city of houston's
roads blocks shapefile and if you have
any experience with arcgis
geocoding specific addresses if you go
anywhere over
like 200 to 2 000
values you're going to run into problems
and you're going to have to stop
start paying them a lot of money so i
had no interest in doing that whatsoever
all of these luckily solvable with
python and some different libraries that
i was able to pull in
so first of all i created a script to
generate a list of the urls for the
police beats
they aren't updated in a very timely
manner usually there's about a two-month
delay so i kind of
solved for that and use date time and
time
again all of this is up on github so if
you have any questions please let me
know but
you can see there's just like a list of
police beat numbers
list of months and you cycle through
them
pulling from blast and then
cycle through the list of urls pulling
everything from the span tag
if the formatting was different so utf-8
versus unicode i used
the unicode decode error also requests
to check for 404's
csv for being able to append to an
output csv
file a beautiful soup for the for the
web scraping
and was since they're all tables with
again the same format
um it was really pretty simple to do
that
and then anything with the same column
name
you just check for column name and sort
of move it around
so the results i got a final output csv
with just under a million criminal
offenses
in houston from june 2009 to february
2015. and these aren't
criminal offenses like hey i saw my best
friend
smoking marijuana in his dorm room it's
all like hey
i you know this is a murder this is an
aggravated assault this is a burglary
this is a theft like these are pretty
severe crimes
and they're now divided into city blocks
with standard formats for
columns and block names so things that
you can actually use in a gis capacity
they're compatible with the city of
houston's enterprise roads
shapefile and if anyone was curious my
district
is responsible for 5.125
of the total crimes despite only housing
4 of the population and covering 18
miles
so it's that really really tiny pink
block
that you see sort of in the center of
houston
so um what am i going to
do with the data now like we've got i've
gotten to the part
of i've obtained it it's a pretty
substantial file
should probably end up being a data
frame or some sort of
database that i house
and also i would really like to do this
for the majority of houston so if
someone
really does have that question like
where should i park my car on west timer
what's the safest drop for me to get to
work they would be able to answer that
without having to use arcgis and do the
network analyst tool
so next steps i would like to
incorporate the 311 data
which is noise complaints garbage and
yards water sewage outages and they
still have
the the terrible monthly download by
district
csv format so ripe for web scraping
and then putting everything online with
an open source gis
so people are able to query crime rates
for given blocks
and route them around potentially
dangerous
areas so
thanks to a lot of people but
particularly
the node co-working space they let me
hang out yesterday and
i think a couple of people from there
are actually here this afternoon
open houston which is responsible for
even putting
any of the data online for me to have
access to
and also my earth science classmates for
asking the questions that made me do
this project in the first place
so there you go